next speaker really needs no
introduction it's a former Secretary of
Defense William Perry you know quite
often when people start with quite often
talk about risk of nuclear war and talk
about how maybe we should reduce our
nuclear arsenals rather than increases
quite often this is dismissed by saying
all these people saying that they're
just a bunch of tree huggers who don't
know anything and I've heard this quite
often and I'm sure you have as well
now this description about tree huggers
who don't know anything it doesn't
really fit very well on any of the
speakers I've heard so far in this
conference all the professors and other
experts and there's nobody on this
planet I think that description fits
less than the next speaker William Perry
because this is the man who was in
charge of our nuclear arsenal who knew
more than anybody else undoubtedly even
more than President Clinton whom he
served under because he was the one who
who really had to deal with it and he
has an amazing personal story that will
come back and talk a bit more about he
has and the one most wonderful thing
about his adventures and it's thanks to
him in no small part that Ukraine went
from having 2,000 nuclear weapons to
having zero the whole nunn-lugar
initiative implementation where we in
the u.s. paid cash to get rid of
dangerous highly enriched nuclear
materials to be turned into civilian
electricity in the US and so on he's got
so many wonderful things and amazingly
he just came out with this fantastic
book which I just finished reading it's
really a page-turner and if anyone is
interested in buying it the good news is
we can actually be having a for sale at
5:00 p.m. at the end of this session and
even better news he actually has kindly
volunteered to sign it for you also if
you'd like so
we have several boxes here before we
bring him up here so he can give his
take on this he asked me to start this
by by doing sort of Freudian thing and
delving into his subconscious so I'm
going to start by showing you one of his
worst nightmares the lights to get into
the spooky spirits of nightmares in a
coverage section of a massively hardened
centrifuge facility a team is by July
3rd they achieve their target of 90% of
issues then transferred the uranium from
nearby secret lab for another team of
technicians of samples
occurred nuclear war on August 31 they
finished they put the bomb in fact great
mangled agriculture and transported to a
nearby airfield where it is stored in a
warehouse two weeks later is removed and
loaded onto an aircraft with civilian
air cargo Marcus
applies to Dubai where they create this
transfer along with other groups and
equipment for global air transport
freighter destination Washington DC
the plane lands at Washington Dulles
International air
2:47 a.m. on September the 15th my late
afternoon the crate is delivered to a
warehouse the southeast part of the dish
then before tapers on September the 17th
the bomb you create
and voted on for dentistry several hours
late an American citizen eases the drop
out into traffic
she drives into location on Pennsylvania
midway between the White House and the
Capitol
at 11:09 a.m. she stops in the middle of
truck rhymes down and triggers today the
bomb explodes for the power 15 kilotons
there are more than 80,000 in some
deaths including the president the vice
pres Speaker of the House and 320 member
lasondra stresses when the bomb resolved
there are also more than 100,000
seriously war and virtually no place to
treat them how our communication to some
of these throughout the Greater
Washington area have gone down soon
cable news and broadcasting see the vast
devastation from the gap all major news
outlets report receiving an identical
message the message claims and five war
bombs are given by different cities
across the country is that one of these
bombs will be set up each week for the
next five weeks unless all American
troops based overseas orders returned
immediately to the US oh man
the nation is growing fat
everything begins shutting down within a
half-hour the stock market drops more
than 70% before radius all from coast to
coast masses of people be in the stream
out of cities no matter their size or
location there is widespread with cell
phone systems as soon
and calls do not go to Internet access
is impossible in many regions and the
nation is now in a constitutional crisis
by succession the Senate President
pro-tem is now the country specific but
he had been treated for pancreatic
cancers robbed the capital and may
affect secretary defense and the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
both of whom were just buying the House
Armed Services Committee on the recent
banking requests are dead
martial law is declared in washington
and surrounding regions and the next day
the entire country there is widespread
looting and violence in many cities
federal and National Guard crews from us
tsundere reports troops environment
baths
there are increasing numbers of reports
of crowds thrive and gives immigrants
and forums within days no Terry begins
to construct large detention centers
around
well that video showed you the possible
catastrophic outcome of one one nuclear
bomb out of the 15,000 during the world
my main message to today is in my
judgment the danger of a nuclear
catastrophe is higher today than it was
at any time during the Cold War higher
today than during the Cold War I lived
through the Cold War at firsthand
experiences of just what this danger was
we talked a little bit about them today
we had all during the Cold War the
possibility of a nuclear war by
miscalculation either by the leaders of
the United States with Soviet Union
the poster child I suppose for a war by
miscalculation was the Cuban Missile
Crisis I was a young analyst at that
time and was called upon to work with a
small team that everyday worked all day
studying the intelligence that came in
from that day and by midnight we had
prepared a report to go to President
Kennedy the next morning helped guide
him through his decisions the next day I
at that time every day I believed when I
went into that analysis center which
probably my last day on earth
I was just close enough to it I knew
just how dangerous it was and to this
day I believe that we survived that
crisis more by good luck than by good
management and everything I have learned
since then has only confirmed that
judgment
today we do not have Cuba as a crisis
but we have Ukraine and potentially
could have the Baltics indeed if the
Russian forces go into Ukraine to the
Baltics the way they went into Ukraine
they will be confronting NATO troops
there will be a military conflict - in
Russian troops and NATO troops and the
danger of course is that conflict could
escalate into a nuclear war beyond the a
war of miscalculation all during the
Cold War every day during the Cold War
we face the possibility of an accidental
nuclear war I myself was experienced
three different false alarms one of them
was very personal I got a phone call at
this at this time I was the
Undersecretary of Defense I got a phone
call at 3 o'clock in the morning and I
picked up the phone the voice on the
other and identified himself as the
watch officer at the North American Air
Defense Command and the general got
right to the point he told me his
computers were showing 200 ppm on the
way from the Soviet Union to the United
States I will never ever forget that
moment for one - heartbreaking instant I
believe we were about to experience the
thickets ask me that we had avoided
during the Cuban Missile Crisis of
course it was a false alarm the general
happily had recognized as a fossil why
was he calling me
I was the undersecretary for research
and engineering he was calling me
because he want to feel what the hell
had happened to his computers that give
him this false signal I could not help
that we couldn't figure it out that and
I took us two days to learn as you heard
from Elizabeth this morning that it was
a operator had mistakenly put a training
tape and at the computer it was human
error
today we still have the policy of launch
on warning we do have the possibility of
reliving the experience I've told you
about what saved as then was the context
what was happening the end was nothing
going on in the world it suggested to be
a problem the other examples that
Lizabeth gave you this morning again
nothing was happening to suggest there
should be an attack and that context was
very important in avoiding a disastrous
nuclear war had that false alarm
occurred during the Cuban Missile Crisis
or during the earlier Mideast crisis
there might have been a very different
outcome since it's also true in the case
of a war by miscalculation that context
is everything the bad news today is that
the context is becoming ugly again
between the United States and Russia and
the many reasons for this one of them
you heard about today was the beginning
restarting of a nuclear arms build-up in
a sense we're about to relive the
nuclear arms race we had during the Cold
War that's one very dangerous that aside
from the billions of dollars going to be
spent about that which you heard about
there's the danger that caused by
creating the context there are other
contexts in terms of the rhetoric this
case mostly rhetoric from Russia to the
United States were not exclusively the
head of Russian media a government
appointed by President Putin as stated
in about a year ago in the Russian media
that Russia is the only nation capable
of turning the United States into
radioactive ash which of course is a
true statement the question is not
whether it's true or false questions
what motivated him to make that
statement
a scientist in Russia working under
government version Lab recently
announced that he was studying a way of
the effects and how he could affect a
huge volcanic explosion exposing the
United States by dropping a hydrogen
bomb on Yellowstone Park though some of
you may be familiar with the fact that
Yellowstone is a home of a dormant but
very powerful volcano and he was
speculating how they might be able to
cause that to often destroy the United
States with volcanic ash he neglected to
point out that that happened it was also
up the story Russia with volcanic ash
that was a oversight in this calculation
I think
and then there's been this famous story
about Russian robotic subs being
developed all of these are in a sense
stupid bluster stupid because without
these fanciful weapons Russia already
has enough conventional nuclear weapons
to destroy them our us and them several
times over but the bluster creates this
very dangerous context that makes an
accidental nuclear war or warlike
miscalculation from a very very low
probability so not such a low
probability beyond that and dota
experiences those are dangers we live
during the Cold War besides that there
are dangers of the news since the Cold
War the possibility of a nuclear
terrorist attack which we just gave you
a hypothetical bit gripping scenario of
how that could happen and the
possibility of a regional nuclear war
regional nuclear war could be between
Pakistan and India so you say why should
we care that's way on the other side of
the earth well first of all we should
care about the tens of millions of
people who would be killed and that and
secondly it can become quite home
because you heard this morning that
nuclear war in Indian Pakistan could
very well caused a nuclear winter which
would affect everybody on the planet
so in sum I have bringing to you today I
think a distressing message and so we
have to somehow look for hope but what
we could do to change the environment
we're now which is causing this
dangerous situation
you have heard just in the last session
and other sessions today things that
people are trying to do to change the
situation and I commend those to your
attention I myself believe that there's
going to be a long hard slog it's going
to involve to succeed we have to
involved many more people than the
people who are sitting in this room it's
going to involve a program I think of
mass education so the more the public
understands the extent of the danger
which indeed we all face today and
that's led me to dedicate the balance of
my life to this process of education
I've written the book for that purpose
but I understand the books only get
through to select few and so I'm having
that book translated in six or seven
different languages so will be read in
China and Russia Japan Korea other
countries as well I'm making a online
version of the book available
I've taken my lectures in my courses at
Stanford I'm transforming them into
what's called a MOOC a massive open
online course on the theory if I want to
get across to young people I have to go
to the Internet to do that everyone gets
to large numbers of people I have to go
to the Internet to do that I have formed
a project called WJ Perry project which
is directed by my daughter Robin Perry
who's sitting here also my son David
Perry is working on that project
particularly the education aspect of the
project and together we are trying to
work hard to get the message across what
the danger is at what people might be
able to do about it
I have been asked by some like friends
and colleagues why I am spending my
golden years on what is as a Sierra
hopelessly idealistic unrealistic view
of trying to transform such a major
aspect of our civilization today and I
answered them by quoting give them a
quote from Andrei Sakharov some of you
may have heard of Andrei Sokolov the
Russian scientist who is largely
responsible actually for the development
of their hydrogen bomb but after he left
his field of science he became he
devoted the last years of his life to
political reform in the Soviet Union now
can you imagine something more
hopelessly unrealistic than trying to
affect political reform in the Soviet
Union in the 70s and he received the
same kind of a comment from his friends
that I get for my friends and here's how
he answered them I like this he said
there is a need to create ideals even
when you cannot see a path to achieving
them because if there are no ideals then
there is no hope he pursued his ideals
he kept hope alive in the Soviet Union
for major political reforms and that is
the message on which I'm going to end my
talk today we must pursue our deals
ideals in order to keep hope alive that
we can have a world without nuclear
weapons for our children and for our
grandchildren I thank
you stay here in here you know
Wow
we have time for lots of for questions
so please line up at the two microphones
and I'm just so touched no my father is
88 so if if William dr. William Perry
can do this at 88 we can't do anything
come on Never Say Never
yeah so I was secretary defense when I
was a secretary defense we dismantled
8,000 nuclear weapons half of them in
the Soviet former Soviet Union and half
of them in the United States in fact my
top priority when our secretary defense
was the dismantling of the deadly Cold
War nuclear legacy and for four years we
succeeded in doing that but going
backwards today
I can't think of a better embodiment
either of the the spirit of MIT than you
here you combined like the geekiness of
a mathematician a PhD in math through
the analyst is really very rational
analytic approach to things with the
ideals the passion and look at the
amazing results that that can give so we
can hack it we can do it you first I am
sure you know the correctness of or can
correct me on my vague understanding but
I wish you would my understanding is
that in the Cuban Missile Crisis Curtis
LeMay of the Air Force in the Cabinet
Room was advocating a first strike
against the Soviet Union and Cuba and
that the other military officers
involved in the Joint Chiefs I believe
agreed with that and I'm not sure there
were any people in the room other than
Robert Kennedy and the President himself
who who were firmly opposed to starting
a nuclear war what what was the
composition of the vote if you want to
put it that way let me emphasize I was I
think thirty years old at the time
I was a young analyst playing a very
small role sending messages up to the
top I have no idea what happened in
those catacombs I have read however
several books including McNamara's book
which more or less agree with what's
been described here but I have no
first-hand information on that
secretary Perry that was very very
inspiring I've been trying to get a
message to our Nobel Peace Prize winning
president to try and do something about
this in one sense you only need a few
people to change things I've talked to
John Holdren his science advisor and
Rose Gottemoeller his nuclear adviser
talking to them about the climatic
effects and pointing out that President
Obama can reduce our weapons without a
treaty with Russia the treaty says the
maximum number not the minimum number so
have you been more successful at talking
to President Obama and urging him to do
this say first of all of something for
President Obama his speech in Prague
which he made just several months after
taking office was one of the most
eloquent and passionate pleas for the
elimination of nuclear weapons I can
still remember how thrilled I was when I
heard that speech I don't think we'll
probably ever get a president who knew
more about the subject and cared more
about the subject that he did his first
few years in office he actually had a
very successful set of actions including
a negotiation of the New START treaty
with Russia most importantly I think he
started the nuclear summits the nuclear
summit is the single best thing that
this country has ever done to reduce the
danger of nuclear terrorism because a
terrorist would only get a nuclear
weapon as suggested in this video if
they can get a hold of the fissile
material and what the summit's goal is
is to get better control of the fissile
material all over the world the last
meeting that summit as you know was just
yesterday
and my main I have several messages the
present I'm trying to get a customer
that's not one of them one of them is
please work to continue the work in the
nuclear summit beyond this last meeting
either by having more summits follow-on
summits which I recommended or secondly
if that doesn't work out at least
creating the institutional process which
will continue the work of trying to get
better control of fissile material the
other message I have to him is for God's
sakes let's reengage with russia the
context we're talking about which makes
it so dangerous comes from the hostile
us Russian relationships which in many
ways are worse than they were during
many years of the Cold War I understand
the President Putin and President Obama
cannot stand to be in the same room with
each other there's a personal animosity
there but I think both president have to
rise above that personal animosity and
consider the responsibilities they have
in the position that they must meet
again
they must talk seriously about nuclear
day certainly the nuclear terrorism is a
is a danger which both countries face it
that video that I showed you could just
as well have happened in Moscow has
happened in Washington so it's a problem
for both countries and the least we can
be doing is working together on that
problem nation-to-nation if we could
succeed in cooperating in fact maybe
that would break the ice enough that we
start working together on other issues
as well so I come in with much amendment
more much more limited objectives and
goals you realize have some feeling
political achieve building I try to
recommend things I have some hopes that
it would be achieved
my name is Christina Martinez in Thank
You mr. Perry for being here I want to
ask you you're my colleague um Matt yeah
here who's a great pleasure to meet a
medium to learn the very great work he
is doing and I learned a lot and listen
the other speakers at this conference
but please go ahead thank you very much
correct me if I'm wrong
first of all I want to ask two questions
which are related number one
the North Atlantic alliances was built
to counter the verso pact
why after the collapse of the Soviet
Union NATO still exists actively second
regarding the Berlin Wall it is mass
under my understanding that there was a
quid pro quo a agreement between
President Reagan and Gorbachev and that
was that the Berlin Wall went down and
NATO Odin move one each to the east
induction on the
the first question when the Cold War
ended
NATO saw the possibility of creating a
security organization for all of Europe
including Russia and we started out I
think in the right direction we created
something called the partnership for
peace which invited former Warsaw Pact
members and former republics of the
Soviet Union to join us and we conducted
together joint peacekeeping X military
operations be joint peacekeeping
operations and during the Bosnian war
which was a peacekeeping operation
sanctioned by the United Nations most of
those were so Pact nations joined us
remarkably Russia sent a brigade to
Bosnia operating under an American
general and an American division it took
me four meetings with the Russian
minister defense to get an agreement for
how that was going to happen but it did
happen so for four or five years their
NATO was a force for peace and for
bringing the east-west together what has
happened since then
I think stimulated primarily by NATO's
decision to expect to expand its active
membership to the East and Russia to
alienate become alienated from NATO and
drop away from it I think was a tragedy
but NATO itself was serving and could
stupid a very useful purpose in bringing
peace the whole area encouraged to
observe that function have not taken the
wrong direction to see that peace we're
not moving in that direction at all now
I'm sorry to say I'm the second okay
let's do want to make sure we give
everybody a chance so let's hear your
question thank you again
yours hello Ian Brinkley here I work
with LaRouche PAC I agree with what you
said that we are probably closer to
nuclear war than we've ever been but I
disagree with what you said on as to the
cause of it
you implied in your remarks that it was
on account of Russia's hostile posture
to the United States when in reality
it's the United States which is
currently the biggest purveyor of
violence and warfare on the planet under
the direction of President Obama we are
allied with nations which sponsor
terrorism openly Saudi Arabia and Turkey
being a couple of them we were the ones
who organized the takeover of the
government of Ukraine as was Victoria
Nuland was literally caught on tape
organizing the coup there so wasn't
Russia and China and Russia have
consistently offered to the United
States collaboration on the things we
need like fighting terrorism as you saw
what Putin did in Syria which was
successful whereas as our operation was
not like you see with China on yes I do
thank you those is very interesting
points you make I want to make sure that
we let everybody ask questions so I
think there's enough in there already
for it to get some good answers just
what question is that
would you agree that President Obama's
policy is now pushing us towards nuclear
confrontation with Russia and China why
would you my answer is No
okay next next the question and make
sure the pain that these are questions
not statements maybe that we'll have
plenty of chances to discuss this later
okay good hi I'm Louisa I'm a student
here at MIT I'm sorry this I have a
question I have one brief thing to say
before that which is just that for the
earlier question about the Cuban Missile
Crisis if you weren't aware the archives
of all the conversations that President
Kennedy had while he was negotiating
what to do and deciding are available
online
they're extremely interesting I highly
recommend you check them out and the
statement that Bobby Kennedy and JFK
were the only ones of people have a
question I did over the statement that
Bobby Kennedy and JFK were the only ones
opposed to military action is accurate
my question is what do you see as the
role for Engineers and just you know
academics in general in working towards
a more peaceful world especially like
given the climate we have today with
Russia first of all they should speak
out now second of all first of all that
should think and study the problem
secondly they should speak out exactly
and third they should be open to going
into either advising the government of
going into the government as I did I did
I must say I did not volunteer for it I
was drafted but I'm glad I did it and
it's open to all scientists all right we
have time for 2-3 more questions maybe
even all four of you if if there are
questions and if they're very short so
when you set a gold standard here for us
okay I'll try my best max Charles
Ferguson Federation American scientists
it's been a pleasure work with dr. Perry
about eight or nine years ago Council on
Foreign Relations very inspiring work
that he has done so okay my question is
getting to the one D word or two D words
deterrence and disarmament I'll ask them
about deterrence do you see this as a
roadblock in some sense to getting at
nuclear weapon-free world but on the
other hand having worked with people in
Japan and South Korea and having been to
China last year in a strategic dialogue
especially East Asia the lady earlier
asked about NATO how do we handle these
issues of nuclear deterrence we have key
allies still wanting quote-unquote the
protection of nuclear weapons while
we're trying to move toward a nuclear
weapon-free world Charles I think
nuclear deterrence is greatly
misunderstood and overrated but having
said that we are sitting we're living
with it for a while and what we must
concentrate on I believe is being sure
that what is happening now in terms of
nuclear armament in terms of the
policies even we have a focus on as long
as we have deterrence we understand this
for this complete that our nuclear
weapons are for the sole purpose of
preventing a nuclear attack on the
United States we are in danger I think
of growing moving to policy different
from that more belligerent than that
which meant more dangerous so while I
have my concerns and hesitations about
nuclear deterrence as a policy I think
while we have we should be sure it is
focused on that one one it objective
all right quick question yeah I'm
excited to hear that so on President
Obama is planning to visit Hiroshima
this year where come from my question is
if that happens uh what do you expect
him to do in Hiroshima if if President
Obama goes Hiroshima I have I would
recommend that he do you make a speech
while he's here
he used the occasion of her emotion what
should the to make a speech what should
the subject of the speech be he's not
going to make a speech apologizing for
Hiroshima there are millions of American
lives at stake if they'd had to evade
you to Japan and tens of millions of
Japanese life is at stake
so that's not going to be what he's
going to do even if I recommend it to
him which I would not I recommend what
he would do is take that occasion to
point out the inhumanity of nuclear
weapons the perfect example of the right
right in front of us and in Hiroshima
and pledged that he would do everything
he could do and everything United States
could do to ensure that nuclear weapons
are never ever used again look do wait
all right I can make it quick all right
make it quick we will have I think we're
going to cut that this you'll be the
last questions for now but don't despair
because you'll have one more chance to
ask dr. Perry questions later because
he's also going to be on the discussion
panel
all right so dr. Perry just quick first
quick question is what do you have and
do you have a message for somebody who's
just a young scientist for with a degree
who which has no practical use a PhD in
math just like yours what can I do more
than just that I'd stay investing the
money that I don't have yet to help the
second quick question is nobody brought
it up today so people are starting to
worry about artificial intelligence
have you ever thought
have you ever heard the worries about a
combined effect of artificial
intelligence and nuclear weapons just uh
there is a new emerging danger with
nuclear weapons tied to science one than
being a cyber a potential of a cyber
attack on our command and control system
on the Soviet on the Russian command
control system and the and there's
theoretically some application about
artificial intelligence here nothing
I've ever read or what has been thought
of a proposed they're making very much
sense to me I must say so I can't say
much about how artificial intelligence
might be used in this particular
problems played a major role another
field vital to you role yet in this road
that may be my lack of understanding
rather than the pact but I think the
major concern today is that there could
be some sort of a malicious cyber attack
either on our cabana control system or
on the Russians command control system
which would do greatness chief great um
Haley from Tufts is going to get the
very very very last question before we
go last questions always their worst
it's a big one so I'm a freshman at
tough studying international relations
and I was wondering if you could offer
me some career advice of where I should
go like pursue my career in the federal
government to cause the biggest change
in social impact what's your major a
tough international relations and my
recommendation would be not to go to try
to go directly in the federal go but try
to stab yourself as a career in some
other field first and then from that
position pivot into the government at a
later time when you have word off for
the government absolutely under
experience in in academia or an industry
to take with you when you go into the
government that's based on my limited
experience of going into government I
never only did a one only this twice in
my life okay and I did a pivoted once
from and industrial job and the second
time when acted that meets your option B
thank you
all right let's
you